vaping was sold to the public as a tool
to help smokers give up their addiction
the medical industry says that's rubbish
and has welcomed a federal government
decision to ban the import of disposable
single-use Vapes into
Australia vaping that's happening in
this country is hurting people hurting
the environment and it's just a terrible
thing hooking in new generations so uh
all these measures I think I hope
countries around the world will look at
what's happening in here and see it as a
model for helping and protecting people
in their own countries vaping in
Australia is limited to those who have a
prescription and Vapes required for
medical reasons are available at
chemists and
pharmacies despite these restrictions
the uptake of ecigarettes is still on
the increase a study by Australia's
cancer Council found nine out of 10
teenagers had Vaped we've seen retailers
flout the laws and sell these products
to young people so uh these rules are
fundamentally necessary and we are
certainly keeping a watching brief on
whether we do see in fact A reduced use
and access of these products by young
people next year it's with that in mind
the federal government is targeting a
thriving Black Market with flavored
disposable Vapes imported from China
being sold illegally through convenience
stores as well as Banning the Imports of
disposable Vapes the federal government
plans to introduce legislation to
prevent local manufacturing and
advertising and from March the Imports
of personal Vapes will also be band but
the industry says this approach is
driving the black market and Vapes
should be regulated the same way as
cigarettes right now you just have a
rampant Black Market 90% of vapers are
accessing products that have no product
standards under the table and buying
them through crime syndicates and we're
just saying you can tax and regulate
better products that consumers can
access that argument has fallen on deaf
ears with Australia now legislating some
of the toughest nicotine controls in the
world Sarah Clark Al jaaz Sydney
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer